this program is brought to you by Emory
University
you know the best gift
I tell you I just believed that all of
this happened so perfectly all these
people were brought together for a
reason and I just felt that way ever
since week you know we've got all this
organized went out when i heard thats
gonna be given to though you know seven
year old little boy I was just like
ready to do it so just just meant a lot
to melt I love kids I you know might I
have a three-year-old nephew and I know
if he was you know in the same situation
like it would you know I would speak
with more than willing you know to give
to him or or would want somebody to be
able to give to him and he's awesome
reminds me of how I was when I was when
I was that age latest he loves video
game was like me and that's well that's
all we've been talking about it's just
going storm playing video games like
he's a new boy he were just at the
playground the other day he's running
jumping climbing making friends running
around lots of energy it's good to see I
think it's just amazing I mean my wife
and I were talking about last night if
we'd ever get to meet everybody in one
room and walked in to the hospital this
morning for labs and lo and behold I
overheard a conversation talking about
the story that we did pre-op that was
online and they had seen it and I just
overheard him I said oh by the way that
was that's me in my family and they were
like oh and then it all kicked off and
then it turns out that the other donors
were sitting the next row over and we
all just met and it was really really
amazing he already named his two what's
the name okay and where'd you get the
name from what cartoon vinton
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University